if you're gonna make something it's part
of a story it started before you came in
contact with the materials and will
continue long after Jonathan's autism
made me think why I'm building this
house he taught me responsibility I was
investing in my block I was investing in
my life there is an alternative way to
live we are trying to use 3d printing to
show that homelessness is a solvable
problem and now we're in the business of
community building
we're here to change things we're here
to make things different
there's probably good reason why they've
always made a door like that
why that's usually the way it is but
what if it wasn't
some individuals instead of asking why
ask why not you can build castles out of
grass what else can you do
homes built out of recycled materials
would be contributing rather than taking
I don't know if I can change the world
right now I can change my world one of
the unexpected byproducts of believing
in my neighborhood is that it's allowed
me to feel safe the free and home
[Music]
you